thank you
yes
[Laughter]
[Music]
that is
what's up
you know
[Music]
many times
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
I am
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
from me
[Music]
and welcome back to the realest podcast
in the Dunya three Muslims alhamdulillah
we here join again with the job until
anhill can get back inshallah very soon
child my brother how you doing
alhamdulillah
man how you doing
[Music]
you guys hope you enjoy the new
Countdown the recitation of
um
I mean I mean let us know what you mean
and uh we're using a new streaming
platform right now so if you find any uh
glitches or anything let us know
inshallah so we can fix it and let us
know the quality is looking so far
Bismillah someone commented uh on how it
looks different
someone said the same thing last time
yeah uh to brother is Echo
that might be my end let me see
no I don't think so actually okay let me
mute you guys let me know
hello
does someone have it playing
yo what if someone in one of your houses
is just playing
our stream
I do hear I hear that I hear it as well
like uh Judd is your mom streaming the
three Muslims again Mama turn it off
okay I do hear it though I hear it from
someone okay let me mute and then let me
know again if you're here
hello yeah it was you around me I'm not
gonna lie
my body kid let me uh I guess I'll just
turn this down how about now talk hello
you guys better yeah
money all right alhamdulillah let's get
uh Isa out of here bro man I'll bless
you man
a lot of Juicy topics that are very
important for them to be aware of today
you wanna gloss over them
yeah so first and foremost we're gonna
go over
um Dwight from the office Rayne Wilson
is the actor who played Dwight from
office um and uh he's a part of the
faith called the Baha'i faith it's
something that started like in the 1800s
as an offshoot of Shia Islam believe it
or not
um the person calls himself
um I think it's like Allah or someone
like that's supposed to mean the glory
of God but his name
um is something else it's like Mirza
um Mirza Mustafa or something like that
so yeah another one of those um with all
due respect uh kind of uh it seems a
little more liberal if I'm going to be
completely honest and we will get into
that Insha'Allah so again the story from
the office you think the Baha'i faith
was taught about someone named mirrors
or something yeah yeah just like music
bro this is wild yeah yeah
I'm gonna think twice before name myself
yeah yeah inshallah we're gonna we're
gonna dissect all of that and uh but
mainly I want to focus on rain Wilson's
belief because he has a lot of spiritual
beliefs but I think are beautiful and in
line with Islam a lot of time so we'll
dislike that and then later we'll go to
um Stephen Crowder or as Muhammad hijab
says Stephen cowder or coward because um
he's not willing to talk to any Muslim
but he wants to talk a lot about Islam
and he went on Alex Jones's
um Channel I think is called Infowars or
something like that and said a lot of
crazy stuff which we will play and go
over today Insha'Allah and then towards
the end we might do a call in uh and
we'll see how that goes and um lastly I
want to mention we're going to have a
very special guest of river who's kind
of I think up and coming uh his name he
goes by I think tortoise King may Allah
bless him but his name is John who came
from Christianity to Islam so um
very soon
I'm going back to the 160 viewers that
are here nice and early on time
yes sir yes sir W chat
yeah
someone asked what um who the reciter
was for the intro it's here if you go
rewind you could see
um the name over there we got our man
John tortoise King over here
my brother hope you're doing one shot
in 30 minutes or so
all right so let's uh let's jump right
into it let me pull the video up
first I want to make sure that um
everything goes well with playing it
Judd you're in Texas right
how's everything going bro you don't
have to jump into the water bro when you
said uh plenty of fish in the Cena
well I was like I thought about that
like idea like on the spot I was like
dance looking funny
bro it's nice the weather sucks right
now but it's all cloudy for the whole
week but inshallah you know we'll get it
back I miss it rains man extra
opportunities for Dua that's true that's
very very true but you know sun's out
guns out you know what I'm saying I'm
gonna know I'm trying to get back on the
boat but inshallah soon
sounds good brother all right so let's
um
I'm gonna try and get this uh this video
up over here cap on why what's wrong
with my hair doesn't look the same
all right
I think I think this is the best uh
right here there's also this one but I
think this looks a lot
there's no way to like make us bigger
and close the margins no this is all we
can do either make this bigger or make
that smaller solid
got our first super challenge here uh
Salam Bros is a third stream with nickel
plan Insha'Allah um nothing's planned
yeah but we do plan on making uh making
something in the future hopefully in
person
bigger is this the big head
G oof guys if you know you know yeah you
don't remember big head bro the no neck
ed yeah yeah
let's go into this Dwight
all right the reason why spirituality is
important is because it is reality
so what is reality I'm fully in
agreement with tahar de Chardon who said
we are not human beings having a
spiritual experience we Are Spiritual
Beings having a human experience I fully
know uh goes beyond belief I fully know
that I am a soul and that I am
inhabiting or attached to or in
connection with a bodily form for
who knows how long 60 70 90 years I'm
not sure how long it'll last and that is
my reality and the who I am and what I
am is not my body it's not even my
personality it's not even like the
background that I
you know it's not the trauma I suffered
it's not what I've been through that
there is a little spark of the Divine
inside of me or that is part of me that
is reflecting the Majesty of the Divine
of God the divine presence the creative
Force just like a sunflower turns to the
Sun and follows the sun throughout the
course of the day that is reality so for
me to deny my reality is is not
beneficial to anyone and at least at
least if not myself all right so I want
to pause there and jump because
um
he says some very interesting stuff and
if you don't take the time to really
pick apart while he's saying you might
skip over some of the important aspects
of it so firstly he's not a Muslim he's
like I mentioned a part of the Baha'i
faith which we will discuss inshallah
after the video
um and he is saying some things that
islamically we disagree with to be fair
and get out of the way we don't believe
we have any part of God or like a spark
of the Divine in us or whatever we are
creations of Allah we're her servants we
are created in a beautiful form yes but
we cannot relate that to Allah except
that you know he is he is the
self-sufficient and sustainer and we
need him to exist that's you know the
extent of our existence really
um other than what you know God decrees
for us in our purpose and that stuff
and then he mentioned something very
important that this is beyond belief
it's not I believe it's I know I know
and that's beautiful because in in Islam
you know amen they translate it as faith
Iman is not Faith Iman is the acceptance
of a fact and some Scholars Define it as
well to say that it's the acceptance of
a fact based on evidence as well right
so we we say that the Quran is evidence
of Allah so when we have Iman and Allah
and the prophet sallam and Islam
and the Quran it's based on evidence
it's based on logic and rationality it's
not based on some wild you know I
believe a certain person died for my
sins or anything like that it's based on
evidence and it uh that's a beautiful
part of Islam and so him mentioning that
I think is is really tremendous but what
were your first uh thoughts you know
hearing Dwight from the office talk
about spirituality bro as soon as he
said that it reminded me of the podcast
that we had with I think almost two
years ago if not more than that it was
one of our very first ones and he was
talking about some different verses in
the Quran where it says oh you who
believe or believe this believe that and
understand this but then there were some
verses that say know this know that you
know I'm sure Jad knows about them
um
yeah when I when I came across them bro
I was just like subhanallah like being a
non-muslim himself to understand that
there's some things that are just beyond
theoretical comprehension but they're
kind of it's It's truth bro and the
thing with truth is we all have a part
of Truth in us and when we have exposure
to the truth we have this Affinity to
the truth and it's not anything like
something that someone tells you and
wants you to believe with their own ego
or their own kind of twist to it the
truth is the truth there's only one
truth it's not your truth and my truth
so subhanallah the truth is generally
something that you will know and the
difference between somebody who gets the
truth and someone who doesn't is
literally in that that they get the
truth they accept the truth they
understand it and they resonate with it
yeah I mean it was nice to see you know
someone especially that's um not Muslim
uh hearing someone that actually has
faith in something spiritual in
something something greater it's
something that um kind of lost in the
world especially now that we live in
everyone is it's just it was nice to see
someone like spitting facts you know
um and I completely I mean the part
where he's talking about how like he's
the spirit and he's not who his body is
but he's the spare that's inside of his
body I thought that was I thought that
was amazing and um the ayat that you're
talking about the ones that start with
there's the ayat that start with yeah
it's like you know like know this and
Allah I'm telling us that like these are
facts whatever comes after that so um
but yeah that was that was really
interesting and it was it was really
nice to see
we're going to continue with that in a
second but um
there's a part um before I pause where
he mentioned um you know we're not our
traumatic experiences we're not really
just products of our surroundings you
know we are more than I think that is
something that's very empowering
I think believing you are only a product
of your surroundings and that you can't
change yourself and that there's this
deterministic framework built around
your life that you just cannot protrude
in any way and you're stuck within it
um and it determines who you are and
what you do I think that's a very
depressing life and I think it's an
excuse to get away from accountability
and the idea of Free Will especially the
god-given accountability you know from
our our Free Will and our decisions so I
really like they imagine that because it
really brings back a I mean for lack
better word spiritual aspect to a human
being you are a soul created by Allah
you know it's it's Unique it's beautiful
and it's built in a very specific way
and
just kind of like a car it's you know or
your body's like a car meant to be
driven in a certain way
you know and what you feed your feed
quote unquote your car needs to be
specific to get it to keep going right
if you put the wrong thing in it it's
going to break down if you don't take
care of it properly it's going to break
down our souls are similar as well you
know if you feed it the wrong stuff it's
going to become corrupt and that's why I
lost my data he says you know he who
succeeds is the one who purifies himself
his nuffs his soul and that's where
teskeya comes from
and someone said rhyming I'm going to
try and move my uh microwave inshallah
but you know you could see that's like
there's there's a lot of Islamic
influence in what he is saying I think a
lot of the stuff
from the spiritual sense in the Baha'i
faith probably comes from Islam with a
few probably a heretical twist
100 I wanna I'm waiting for you to get
into I don't know when you want to get
oh sorry sorry whatever you want to get
into is uh his faith because I was
really I want to know what it is that he
believes in I know you wanted to
complete the video but I'm interested to
to understand what his faith is yeah so
I meant to put the video up in the back
end not to actually play it out loud so
that was my bad but there you go yeah so
um the Baha'i faith is
kind of a um so what they believe is
Unity right the one word that always
comes up with them is Unity they believe
that Humanity should all be United
um and that not that all religions are
fully true in a sense but um
that
it's it's kind of hard to say because I
think it's confusing to be honest I
don't think they have any firm beliefs
they follow general principles
um that God has sent and listen to how
similar to Islamic sounds God has sent
Divine teachers like Moses Jesus the
prophet Muhammad peace upon him they
just think the you know Divine teacher
afterwards ended up being this guy who
goes by the name of Baha Allah which
means Glory the glory of God but his
actual name is Mirza Hussein Ali Nuri
um and he was like I mentioned uh kind
of uh from the Shia sex so it's an
offshoot of shiaism that looks to
combine the religions and say that the
Divine teachers of Judaism and
Christianity and Islam came a sequential
time to teach their people a progressive
religion
right to teach their people
a progressive religion and
I think that it's it's it's
very liberal of them to be honest and I
think that's why there's eight million
people who practice the faith right and
by the way almost no dawah to them I
think they're so close to Islam it's
beautiful there's no dawah oh pardon me
my camera went out a bit but while I get
that reopened there's no doubt of being
given to them
and there's
pardon me
I'm gonna it's crazy eight million
people though eight million bro and
they're they're so close yet so far
do you know where they're based at like
where the majority of them or is it kind
of just all spread out
I know a lot of them are in Caribbean
countries and islands like I know in
Belize there's a lot of people that are
Baha'i
um I feel like I've maybe heard the word
but I'm never like definitely not I
don't think I've met anyone or you know
ever like talked to anyone about it
which is really oh listen do you know
this one YouTuber by the name of Elliot
Hulse
uh let me look at Mom am I recognizing
anyone that like was into like OG like
Fitness and self-improvement he was one
of the the goals you said yeah
we had them on the podcast yeah you
probably don't oh you know I reckon I I
definitely see his face he was born as
uh into the Baha'i faith and now he's
wow yeah yeah I definitely seen this guy
before though actually he's not kind of
Christian he's super Christian
wow he was born into it and he left
yeah he kind of left but that did give
him a lot of understanding into things
like like fasting you know as Muslims
and he used to do it all done and he has
a decent understanding of the Prophet
saw him but at the end of the day just
knowing the truth and accepting the
truth are two different things so Rami
do they believe like in do you know if
they believe in like our prophets or
yeah yeah they they believe in all like
the The abrahamic Messengers and
Prophets they believe in Jesus they
believe in the prophet Muhammad peace
upon him that's why I think they're so
close to Islam because listen to what
they say God sent these prophets and
Messengers to reteach the people this
religion they add the word Progressive
but we'll get to that what that means
to teach people a progressive religion
and the most recent of these Divine
teachers was the man who came in the
1800s and so on and so forth and maybe
anyone who you know came after him if
they believe anyone after him
obviously you know we believe that that
is heretical and that it ends with the
prophet Muhammad peace upon him and I
think a very important question for them
is what makes this um who they call
Allah
um you know someone who is prophetic
someone who is a Divine teacher how do
you differentiate a false prophet from a
true Prophet because then Islam is very
simple they have you know Miracles and
prophecies and they come with Revelation
you know what is this guy's Revelation
what did he bring
um that is significant and he was
technically by his own you know a belief
a a Muslim
maybe we wouldn't obviously consider him
a Muslim but that was his upbringing he
grew up in Iran in the 1800s as an
offshoot of the Shiite belief so
anything he's going to teach is probably
going to just going to come from Islam I
think that's why there's a big Islamic
influence on what they say so I would
love to talk to people of the Baha'i
faith and get them on the podcast and
discuss inshallah because like I
mentioned there's no dawa really being
given to them yeah that'd be really
interesting and they probably it
probably be a really easy segue for them
yeah yeah inshallah I hope so because
all we have to do is say listen you're
right God sent these prophets and
Messengers to teach people the religion
eventually people corrupted it so God
sent more prophets and Messengers The
Last of which was actually the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him you're a
person you go and ask your person for
some reason stop there that's where it
stops and look at the Quran you believe
you know the prophet sallam is a prophet
of God look at what he brought the Quran
and it says he is the Seal of the
prophets and in another station the
final Prophet The Last of the prophets
which means there's no one to come after
him we know the Quran has been preserved
therefore this practice Islam all these
beautiful teachings that you're talking
about
we have in Islam as well they actually
come from Islam so I think it'd be
really really primed to give them that
one this way inshallah
how would you answer somebody that's
kind of trying to press you and ask you
how do you know the prophet sallam how
can you prove that he was the last or
the Seal of the prophets
well to okay well it's a universal claim
right I'm claiming he is the Seal of the
prophets uh and if you want to disprove
that Universal claim bring someone after
him show me someone else that was a
prophet after him you'll prove me wrong
if I say every cat in the world is
orange and then you show me any other
color and then I'm wrong right so I'm
making the claim that he is a prophet
and that there's none after him you want
to disprove it bring one person that's
fine
hmm
is that a satisfying answer if it's not
let me know that is satisfying like the
more that we can I guess also establish
the Divine Authority and Truth in the
Quran being the word of Allah being 100
in alignment with objective reality and
truth then you kind of have to go with
whatever the Quran says even if we as
human beings
are lacking the ability to conceptualize
a lot of the things in the Quran yeah
yeah 100 100 so let's get back to this
video inshallah and uh and finish it off
yeah
pardon me you want to put Taurus King in
the video now or later we're gonna
finish the segment about showing him up
after okay if that's cool
oh we can see it right now John okay
good
and you're like that's [__] prove it
to me sorry uh prove to me this Divine
spark of what you speak I want to see it
in a laboratory or in an algorithm or on
a computer screen well that's not quite
how it works because every spiritual
tradition will show you that we live in
The Matrix that we live in an illusion
and when we wake up from this Corporal
form we're going to be in some greater
reality and this is this has come from
the atheists this idea that you know
perhaps we're this we're living in an
avatar a similar the simulacrum you know
and we're living in a fleshy Avatar and
we're going to wake up to some greater
reality but putting all that aside I
would say for to the atheist or agnostic
that try it and see if your life is
better because there is hard uh we
talked about Dr Lisa Miller and her work
there's hard data that shows around
mental health and well-being that having
serenity
meaning purpose focus a sense of service
to other others a losing of oneself to a
Transcendent self of the Divine the
Transcendent the abundance that's around
us increases greatly the quality of Our
Lives when we see ourselves in true
humility with the size and scope of the
universe and whatever infinite universes
are Beyond this universe that it makes
the quality of your life better so cost
benefit analysis putting in a small
amount of time every day I'm talking
about
40 minutes in your day to some kind of
spiritual
um opening and and or practice has
incredible benefits this has been found
time and time again it's found in the
12-step programs it's found in Buddhist
Meditation it's found in the most
ancient texts that Humanity has ever
proved uh created the The Vedas and
upanishads from you know three thousand
years ago this sense that we are a wave
on the sea of creation and the wave
crests and the wave Falls where a part
of something much greater and much more
beautiful than ourselves and in living
in that state can greatly enrich your
life
so
as you can see
very very beautiful teachings honestly
very beautiful teachings I think that
not not only is it very you know
eloquent in this and obviously
well-versed but the message is something
that's beautiful it's something that we
believe in as well and it's I think it's
something that needs to be propagated
you know this
battle against atheism I think is is a
real one it's an important one and we
shouldn't let atheists get away with
this denial of the spiritual because it
goes against one methods but we could we
could talk about that at some other time
but um according to the last you know
half of the clip that we just watched
what are your what are some of your
thoughts
um I thought it was really interesting
he's talking about how studies and stuff
have shown that he's like 40 minutes of
spirituality a day will has proven to
help mental health and all that and then
you look at us Muslims five prayers
about five minutes 25 30 minutes a day
towards spirituality and alhamdulillah
mental health I would say is better than
the average human so it it's just
amazing that you always see these things
and then a study will come out 1400
years later proving whatever he said was
right and it's just
it's just amazing and I think anyone
that has some sort of spirituality in
their life someone that is firm on their
religion someone who has some sort of
belief in
either either a Muslim or someone who's
firm in their own religion their quality
of life is going to be better than
someone who has no faith and they're
just living life and they've taken their
desires as their lord
I mean
it's Allah has told us like that there
is going to be people who take their
desires as their love and once you have
done that what's going to stop you at
that point What's going to stop you from
doing something other than like what's
objective morality it just goes into all
of that but it's um it's just amazing to
get
to see their perspective from someone of
a different Faith kind of saying the
same type of things yeah 100 there's
actually a study done and the conclusion
they came to us only Muslim and I have
it here only Muslim Buddhist and Jewish
respondents have a significantly higher
life satisfaction than the reference
group of atheists so not only
you know do we feel more content but
there is a greater feeling of Life
Satisfaction Just being satisfied in
life compared to atheists so if atheism
is something that is you know truth the
truth and is beneficial all that stuff
why is it so you know contrary to a
productive way for human beings to live
why is it so contrary to human being
satisfaction
so let me play Let me let me play
Devil's Advocate bro so one might ask
like life satisfaction or SWV subjective
well-being why why is that even a
measure of Truth
it depends on who you are this I don't
like to use these arguments because I
don't think it works for everyone I
think it is subjective and I like to
appear to things that are a little more
objective like you know logical
deductions and that stuff but for a
person to take a more humanist or
naturalistic approach you can argue that
since there's a natural inclination to
believe in one God that that is good
evidence that that God exists you could
actually take that approach if someone's
like a crazy naturalist or whatever
that you know this innate belief in God
it doesn't make sense you know a bear is
chasing you and you're gonna oh God
please save me from this Bears I know
you're dead
it doesn't make sense you know oh oh I'm
dying God please bring me food and
you're just sitting there waiting for
food because you're sick you know it's
like it doesn't make sense to appeal to
something that's not naturalistic for
not for for Real Life Solutions it it's
contrary to what we have instilled in us
to survive so the argument that it's
just something humans form to feel
better or whatever I think is a complete
scapego I think humans are very happy
living in a society in a tribe in a
collective group and these are
naturalistic things that bring us
happiness and and contentment and that
stuff but there's a different level a
different type of satisfaction when you
bring the Divine into it and you can
argue that that is
um kind of a point of reference to say
that we were created by the divine
foreign
I also find the miraculous around me
that
many many times in the past religion was
looked at as something as just strictly
religiosity and that kind of led to you
know as you say that that extreme birth
another extreme of kind of new age
spirituality where they they lack and
I'm not saying only having ritualistic
approach is beneficial but they kind of
forego that completely but then you look
at Islam and Islam likes to find that
middle path between spirituality and
religiosity it's not one at the expense
of other you know what I mean
he had that balance but many Muslims
today they they either are misinformed
or they are just completely blissfully
unaware that Islam is actually here to
tell us to work on both that
purification of the nafs and the self
and spirituality is very important I'm
not going to say it's more important or
less important than religiosity but
they're both very important
yeah 100 and by religiosity do you mean
actual physical practices okay yeah 100
I think it's a great point because I
mean if you think about it
things are created within a certain
framework so we live in a liberal
Society if I were to make a religion
from the top of my head I would make it
around a liberal framework it wouldn't
make sense for me to introduce a new
framework because I grew up as a liberal
so those are my beliefs naturally
I might differ a little bit on a few
things but that is the framework I've
been given as soon as the processant
came with Islam it was a completely
different framework a completely
different framework to the point where
Society went from being tribalistic to
being one basically basically basically
a one ummah under one Khalifa and
obviously we had the non-muslims living
there they had their own rules but it's
a completely different framework
completely different ideology from what
they had beforehand you know this is
something that I believe can only come
from you know a very critical uh and
deep thinker or from the Divine from
Allah from God you know the all
knowledgeable the all-wise so we see
that he he completely flips Society with
a whole new framework with the Baha'i
faith didn't really flip anything if
we're being honest they just took what
they already had and like restructured
it a little bit liberally everyone
literally believed pardon me I said can
I just reaffirmed what everyone was
believing but kind of just put it in and
structured it a little bit yeah same
thing same thing with present-day
Christianity for a lot of Christian not
every Christian but a lot of Christians
and that society as a whole whole or
Christian perspective or Christianity
from the you know public perspective and
with the new age spirituality and and
the this weird like new ageism it's all
within a liberal framework you know why
don't they have certain morals that go
go against you know the the liberal
ideology in regards to LG TVs and all
that stuff why don't they differ with
that if they have this whole new
enlightened belief system or something
like that if it's this new age stuff why
is it exactly what liberals believe
except now you're just spiritual ooh you
know all this weird stuff it's like it
doesn't make any sense yeah we were
talking about this what's Nico last week
on the stream that we did within the at
the end of the day you have new age
spirituality liberalism all of these put
you as the human being as the center of
the universe look for Allah but then
when you come into Islam and something a
little bit more bigger than yourself you
understand that you're actually nothing
in the grand Cosmic scale of everything
that you're just something orbiting
around the central you know whatever it
is which is Allah but new age and
spirituality is kind of like you are
Divine you manifest you like it's all
about you it's all about ego
yeah and that's a great point because
it's the same thing it's liberalism
liberalism says focus on yourself you
are special you're the special cupcake
out of the batch you know all this weird
stuff it's like let's be real
there's a there's a there's a lot of
comfort and this is what sneak was
saying I think you go to the same thing
that there's a lot of comfort with
realizing that you're nothing really you
know you drop the ego and a lot of stuff
liberalism is the contrary to that so
I'm glad you mentioned I think that's a
beautiful Point um John do you want to
jump in quickly before we get to the
super chats I just thought that was a
really good plan at the end that people
struggle with being part of something
bigger than themselves and
like
with it that's that's so true this whole
liberal movement everyone wants like the
reason that it's succeeding so much is
because all these people who never got
any attention or Never Felt special and
never felt like you know they were
someone now like there is their chance
to get attention it's their chance to
feel special it's their chance to to
like be looked at and that's why they're
all everyone's jumping in on it and when
you realize that as you guys said you
put your ego aside and
realize that you're part of something
bigger it's you're first of all you
become happier just genuinely happier
you become a better person and it's just
it's just amazing when you when you're
able to do that subhanallah bro and and
what's crazy is you know the greatest as
they say the greatest trick of shaytan
is to convince the world that he doesn't
exist and he does this through many
liberal movements that I've found bro
like when you look at liberalism and
specifically as Rami mentioned this new
age spirituality it kind of tells you oh
you're letting go of the ego you know
you're being enlightened but you putting
yourself at the Forefront of everything
as the thing that everything else
revolves around it just increases your
ego more yeah it's the most feminismol
thing you could do exactly you look at
feminism it's kind of like telling them
oh you know what you're empowered you're
liberated but they're actually
oppressing them even more so the way
shaitaan works with all of these liberal
movements is to create double standards
in people
in a subconscious level that they're not
at at a conscious level so people don't
realize the dissonance but then they
kind of buy their own BS and just it's
like a self-fulfilling prophecy and they
go deeper into it bro yeah 100 the
reason Islam is so much better is
because we're not saying no one's
special you can be special in the eyes
of Allah you could be loved by Allah and
that's the only way for anyone really to
be special because the only real
framework we have comes from Allah Allah
sets the rules in the framework so if
you're loved by him okay you've
succeeded because that will be objective
on the day of judgment you will be
rewarded based off that and your status
will be seen on the day of judgment the
prophet sallam he said that you know uh
White is not better than the black and a
black is not better than a white and an
Arab is not better than a non-arab and a
non-arab is not better than Arab except
by virtue of good deeds and
righteousness or you know in character
so that's something anyone can fulfill
in the eyes of God in the eyes of Allah
and that's why only Allah can fulfill
that role of being everyone's you know
beloved
and we're created with that that hole in
our heart that needs to be filled with
Allah so I think that's why Islam is
triumphant and speaking of the Triumph
of Islam we have our brother here who
says converted to Islam six weeks ago
because of this Channel first and
foremost
your conversions because of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
um Allah has called you back to his
religion and you have answered the call
alhamdulillah may Allah bless you and
reward you and feel free to DM us
inshallah we'd love to get you on the
channel and hear your story
we also got uh can we get him on the
podcast rain Wilson listen everyone go
hit up Rayne Wilson flood his DMS
generously and kindly not you know and
tweet at him and let's try and get him
on the podcast inshaallah I think it
would be amazing to send them the link
to this podcast guys don't come at him
the way you all came and sneaker the
first time and then we have this um soy
girl here spaghetti thanks
I know who it is but nobody else yo
Sam's been Sam's been causing Fitness
since day one come on no yeah remember
when Angel thought it was a guy
yeah rightfully so uh Islam because the
Quran makes you think to ponder this the
self-reflection changes the heart in
such a real way instead of Blind Faith
100 and that is how God created us God
created us to be able to reflect and for
our hearts to change and become sincere
and softened by his words
that's why Islam is so beautiful
all right now with that being said
talking about Islamic reversion in the
Triumph of Islam we got with us no who
knows he's coming up a very special
guest we got with us today tortoise King
salaam alaikum brother how you doing
right now I can't hear you there we go
um
we've been waiting for you yeah I'm so
excited bro
um
all right it's another 100 first and
foremost welcome to the stream welcome
to Islam why don't you begin I know you
made a video on your channel which by
the way everyone it is tortoise King uh
you can go find on YouTube made a video
talk about your version but so why don't
you share a little bit of that with the
audience today
so I was raised in a Christian family so
my dad was Catholic so we went to the
Catholic church till age eight and then
after that we hopped around the
Protestant churches so
um really so recently probably like age
16 for me but I became non-religious
after reading the Bible from ages 12 to
14. so then I lost faith in Christianity
and I was non-religious the next four
years
and then I started working out again and
looking to improve myself in October of
2022. and then I started so I started
working out and then I started looking
to religion to find purpose and I
originally looked back into Christianity
because it felt comfortable but I
quickly realized why I left and Islam
stood out like a sore thumb because they
believe in the universality of God and
God is one and no other religion teaches
that
like Islam does and the structure it
brings in your life is so different from
every other religion that it makes it's
just perfect
absolutely 100 100 so what what was more
specifically some of the things that
stood out to you about Islam was it
something specific in the teachings of
God or our understanding of Allah or is
it just the the Muslim communities
firmness on the Oneness of God
so it came from more like the Old
Testament because I was raised from a
Christian background so I believed in
the Oneness of God uh the Jews teach
that like God is one and I saw a switch
in the Bible when you get to the New
Testament that the teachings of
Salvation switch from God is one don't
associate partners with him to Jesus's
salvation and that that was a huge
inconsistency for me and that completely
destroys the whole Narrative of the
Bible but I always believed in the
Oneness of God and I knew that his power
couldn't be contradicted he's
all-powerful he has control of all
things
because without control of all things
you're not an all-powerful being that
created everything yeah 100 100 very
beautifully said Allah um I do have a
few more questions but if any of the
brothers want to jump in you know feel
free
you're gonna ask her I'll ask Captain
bro all right now so how long have you
been Muslim for
so I convert on February 16th of 2023 so
we're approaching the three-month Mark I
think wow wow how has it been so far
amazing wow wow tell us about that what
what parts of it are amazing
so the structure obviously makes a big
difference for my life style because
when I was non-religious like I lacked
so much purpose followed my desires like
everything the Quran says is what
actually happened reality but when I
left Christianity initially I thought
all right I might be held down by a book
I I have good judgment I'm not gonna
fall from my ways and I fall from my
ways
and then I was looking for guidance
again and the Quran is so
straightforward I knew that Islam was
the only way wow wow it's kind of lost
beautiful and uh do you have a copy of
the Quran with you yes you actually wow
I feel let's see them
all right so
I am a subscriber sent this one to me
it's a full transliteration one wow
that's awesome
but for my personal ones I have one with
Arabic translation I bought it on Nazi
for like 40 bucks
yeah I'll get it on my case real quick
where are you located at
Ohio
be going down in Ohio
flag like Ohio
so this one's my main Quran the one I
read every day and it's a really
beautiful copy it's a that's like the
pages that's awesome you know how to
read Arabic uh not yet I've been
learning that's awesome
man's ahead of the curve that's amazing
brother bless you I can't say in Arabic
you can watch yeah pray in Arabic you
said wow so you can recite and
everything
yeah I can really say
please
that's amazing man you want to give us a
recitation okay
so
[Music]
Bismillah
foreign
[Music]
in I mean uh so well that was amazing
man
that was amazing brother may Allah bless
you very impressed only a few months in
four surahs memorized man this is so
heartworm may Allah bless you immensely
my brother
out of the curve bro man I'll keep you
shouting bro
by the way the comments love you man
I do have a question around me if you
were done with that yeah yeah okay
Bismillah so I think many of the viewers
including maybe even brother Rami and
Jared are wondering how was Ramadan and
did you participate in Ramadan
yes I did participate in Ramadan the
whole time I actually did it for an
extra day I started a day early wow I
cover it on my channel the whole
experience and I even the interview with
Jesse emmerton which is another Muslim
guy he converted about a month ago so we
talked about it there and to summarize
it basically so uh the first few days
like fasting and like not being able to
drink water during the day it was like
really difficult because I always stay
hydrated but after the initial few days
like it got easier but you had to like
plan out your day you couldn't just run
through the day so like at night time
you have to eat and drink a lot same
with early morning so you had that
planned out and then one interesting
story I have from Ramadan was uh during
Easter so my whole family had an Easter
feast and I was the one fasting and my
aunt she's like 90 and Christian and she
knows nothing really about Islam and
then I'm fasting and she's like really
suspicious so inshallah we can tell her
a lot inshallah maybe Allah will guide
her you know through you man that would
be such an honor I mean it shows yeah
what was your what was your like
favorite part of Ramadan
on did you have a mosque you were able
to go to no I wasn't able to attend the
mosque so I live in the middle of the
country so I'm like 50 miles from the
coast
he's 50 miles is crazy but in general I
can get to him 100 100 shallow we'll get
you out to him soon
um but yeah that changes the whole like
Ramadan experience when you get to see
all the people coming together for the
nightly prayer it's amazing but in
Charlotte you're able to experience that
uh next year
inshallah man may Allah bless you mostly
uh honestly you're inspiring everyone
here in alhamdulillah we got a message
from our sister here really impressed uh
really impressed with the watch tortoise
King towards King's progression uh these
last couple of months his dedication is
inspiring happy subscriber here may I
love bless you immensely
all right my brother do you have any
message for the audience
uh I always encourage people to do their
end research because that's how I found
Islam and always take advice from people
you strive to be like don't take advice
from people that like demoralize you
like when I was non-religious I'd take
advice from people demoralize me and but
when you seek the higher purpose you
start finding the people are achieving
stuff like khabib nurmaga menoff and all
all the great Muslims out there and
their examples that's the life you want
to live yeah 100 did Andrew Day have an
influence oh yeah he's how I like
originally found it so I decided like
listen to like self-improvement talks
I'd listen to guys like David Goggins
and then of course Andrew Tate was all
over the internet at the time so his
influence got me looking into it but he
wasn't like the prime reason why I
converted obviously 100 100 that's
beautiful to hear my man and last
question I have for you is would you
have any question or sorry any advice
for Christians who are looking to hit
them
I'd say read the Bible honestly most
Christians don't read the whole Bible so
they like take the advice from a pastor
but they don't truly understand what
they're actually being taught a lot of
the church teachings these days are you
get the feel good verses and it doesn't
cover the main story of the Bible and
once you read the Bible you know the
church teachings are false and then you
can start doing your own research from
there
yeah yeah all right beautiful advice any
questions or comments from the brothers
I'm good man it was an honor to meet you
and I hope I'll ask around me to
give me your contact information so
inshallah we could speak in the future
Charlotte we gotta make a group chat
inshallah
all right for joining us again everybody
this is tortoise King on YouTube our
brother John may Allah bless him
inshallah hopefully you guys will all
see him again very soon go check out his
channel
foreign
that's crazy that sucks though 50 miles
I wish you would have been able to
experience I'm going to the Masjid but
let me make it easy on them bro that's
the thing bro there's there's places
where there's basically not that many
Muslims
but then you got Islam there
and then there's places where you have a
lot of Islam but there's no Muslims or
the the opposite you got you got no
Islam but you got Muslims bro isn't that
crazy you got so many Muslims but then
there's not Islam being properly
practiced yeah
it's a good point man may Allah make it
easy for us and guide our life I mean
now I mean with that being said we got
the um have you seen that from the crop
what do you see that that comment I says
you're finished boy have you seen that
video
backstage bro get in the VIP access yeah
man
he's always welcome always welcome all
right Stephen crowdatone yeah the cream
of the crop the um
I I ran out of uh sayings but yeah
[Music]
I don't know what to say about this guy
I'm still flabbergasted with what's in
this video but it's it's okay inshallah
I haven't seen it so I'm looking forward
to it my bad grand grand
yo who's playing this
let's take a second relax Mr Jones relax
okay I must warn everyone
viewers discretion
is advised the reason I say that is
because you might lose a few brain cells
listening to this so
you know if that happens the three
Muslims is not liable you can hit
upstairs even Crowder with any uh you
know damages done but um let's go into
it but even though it's actually in the
Quran that a Shepherd can have the boy
okay we're already off to a great start
boom what yeah where is this written bro
it's actually in the Quran that a
Shepherd can have what's on the screen
with a boy where Mr Jones where is this
in the Quran
where is this in the Quran and let's see
obviously everyone knows it's not a
thing Islam I tried to find any kind of
electronic trace of this and there is no
such thing online so let's see what our
wise friend Stephen Crowder says in
response to this bogus claim
there's a lot of stuff in the Quran that
I'm not a huge fan of that's amongst
them okay so he's equally just as stupid
let's be real like I'm sorry it's so
easy to to spot a a fraud a fake
intellectual a shoe polisher as Muhammad
a job says or an apple polisher whatever
you want to call it look at this guy he
knows there's no such thing he's never
read something like this in his life
he's never seen something like this in
his life unless they were both on some
weird right-wing website about Islam any
oh yeah that's one of the things I don't
like about them you come on you're just
embarrassing yourself man I've never
even heard these arguments on like
hammer time or Apostles or anyone bro
yeah yeah it's the first it's literally
at first Alex Jones special literally
um Infowars or the the miss Infowars we
don't know at this point Let's uh let's
continue with the video and show let's
see how how much worse it gets
Islam is based on the idea that The
Blessing of Abraham going down to his
you know oldest son Isaac Ishmael was a
lie so you have to believe and this is
why you have so much radical
anti-Semitism it across the Muslim world
if you believe that these people who
carried the books lied and subverted the
text basically from Abraham onward of
course there's going to be some
animosity so it says well every we
believe in the Bible except not
everything else for example in Islam
this was one thing we talked about
recently where they get really mad for
example if you draw mohabbat okay let's
pause there because he says a bunch like
literally three very different vastly
different moronic uh frankly incorrect
points so first and foremost what did he
say he said that SLAM is based on the
idea
that this blessing from Abraham to
Children is a lie what are you talking
about the blessing is a lie what
blessing was a lie
God gave Abraham scripture he gave his
children scripture he made them good
upstanding prophets and he sent them to
their Nations
later on
and he makes his point people change the
scripture he thinks we have this weird
emotional Vendetta against like Jews
because some of them change the
scripture listen I know Crowder you have
a problem with generalizing people right
you it's easy for you to say all Muslims
are like this Muslims don't have this
problem we're not going to look at all
Jews and say oh they all change the
scripture we know there were a few
people who did it for their own reasons
and yeah we're cool with that and that
was a long time ago and we don't care
frankly because we have the Quran we
have something that's a lot more
Superior so
we don't care yeah you have a problem
generalizing but alhamdul we don't what
do you guys think so far
I mean I I guess you can just say
anything nowadays and people will
believe you they're literally just
saying
no basis no fact he's not even trying to
prove it he's just saying it it's just
they're just saying stuff
um that's amongst those then I want to
see what he's about to say and now he's
about to say something crazy
all right let's get back to it then
now I'm not saying you should just go
out and Troll and drama but what I am
saying is hold on that's more offensive
than a religion that says Jesus is not
exactly who he claimed he was right
Muslims believe that Jesus was a prophet
but that he didn't die that the body was
replaced well that sacred religions
certain more so than drawing
again this guy man there's something up
with this guy bro
let's just analyze the argument he made
it's a lot more sacrilegious to believe
that God that Jesus is not God right to
Christians
that's a creep
bro hello is it just me I can't hear
Romney bro
yeah
some of this stuff is a little glitchy
so you know make that for me
but regardless
the belief that Jesus is God you know is
is fundamental it's a creedal issue
in Christianity and the fact that he
isn't is a critical issue in Islam is
drawing the prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him a creedal thing for Christians
do they need to draw him is it a part of
their fundamental beliefs that they must
to draw him or is it something people
just do out of spite and disrespect to
Muslims so with such a moronic
comparison to compare a fundamental
creedal issue that's fundamental to the
religion to someone doing something just
to upset Muslims yeah we get mad when
you draw the prophet peace be upon him
because just like you Crowder in your
video you told your wife you set a
boundary and she crossed it so you got
upset same thing here Muslims have a
boundary that this is disrespectful so
when people have no benefit in doing it
other than pissing us off yeah it's
gonna piss us off that's exactly what
they set out to do when they do it so
that's just a very moronic comparison
hmm
it's up to you guys if you want to jump
in if you want to get back to the video
no I want to finish it you want to kiss
your mic bro what the heck okay
okay let's get back to inshallah
what Muhammad did who was basically
you're not attacking muscles but it's
true he was illiterate and he lived
there at the crossroads at Mecca
basically going after uh the the the the
the the trains the camel trains uh you
know that came through from the East
going west and he would Rob the Caravans
and he just smartly said control people
and I'll take a cosmology of the
dominant religions of Judaism and
Christianity and I'll adopt that and my
own religion yeah and within a
generation after his death they control
the whole Middle East he said
asterianism and I get to have
six-year-old wife
wow amazing simplification of all of
Islam of 23 to 50 years of a whole
generation of people a whole religion
teachings a society being flipped and
reconstructed like I mentioned within
this new framework that changed the
world and it's all summarized with an
illiterate man had an idea robbed a
caravan and then took over the Middle
East boom thank you Alex Jones you
definitely have done your research and
made a compelling argument
um it's hilarious it's funny and what
he's what he's referencing is the
quraish the people who kick the Muslims
out
had a caravan of the Muslim stuff it was
imagine like I had a van full of Alex
Jones and stuff and I'm driving by his
house like haha I got your stuff he's
gonna try and take his stuff back
obviously you know so that's what was
happening the Caravans were traveling
they wanted to take their stuff back a
war broke out they weren't ready for it
they won because the Muslims are just
tough they're dominant they're on top so
they won and then they took control of
of quraisha of Mecca and the process
doesn't let the people keep living he
let the people keep living they already
had Medina right that he let the people
live and then within 50 years or maybe a
little longer Adam they took over not
just all the Middle East but up to like
the borders of China
spread to Africa spread you know uh two
two major parts of the world they
conquered Rome in Persia this is not
something just a small group of people
can do that's why some historians are
one in particular forget his name
compared the Muslims
it's like every it's like Alex Jones and
like the people uh someone's attacking
me right now bro someone sent an EMP to
my house because everything's like
falling apart
but
I'm gonna switch my camera because my uh
my capture card is overheating hmm
fresh I I just get frustrated listening
to that stuff
um yeah my bad guys Bismillah are you in
slow motion now
I know you're good bro in the beginning
hopefully I'll have this all resolved
within um within a little bit you know
my next stream but regardless it's like
you're gonna oversimplify 50 years of a
whole Generation
Um just to be able to dismiss it it's
like listen at least do your research
and I would like to talk to Steven
Carter I'd like to talk to Alex Jones
um or at least you know if they don't
want to talk to uh to us talk to someone
like Muhammad ajab Abdullah and Lucy you
know talk to these people the the higher
dies on here
who are conquer you know for the sake of
Allah instead of just sitting behind
your Echo chamber on rumble.com
because you were kicked off everywhere
else and uh you know and crying about
the nonsense go garbage
can you just pull up that you're
finished boy please
oh the video itself
I don't know where the actual video is
let me see the video is too funny oh
okay let me see if I can find out one
second
yeah but I don't know how like people
actually listen to that and then you're
like Yep this is right
like all you have to do is think a
little bit or just research a little bit
it makes sense for me
you know you know you know if you have a
soundboard on this
you do yeah we should have set it up
beforehand but yeah we have a soundboard
let me uh
let me see if I can fit this one yeah I
think your Echo is back because you
switched
Allah misguided
to some extent yes we got to go by
what's apparent and we do love and hate
for the sake of Allah but a lot of these
people are just they bought the Western
programming the Fox News narrative no I
think this is it
yeah it is bro this is a new one you'll
finish the new one you'll finish
you haven't seen the new one
so aggressive bro just send it send it
link us on the link I'm trying I'm
trying I'm trying to find it oh it's
yeah I I think I remember where it's
where it's from like it's new he's like
reacting to something it looks like he's
like yeah I think that was a discussion
with with Christian Prince or whatever
his name is the new one I think it's old
I don't think there's another one
oh that's okay maybe next time we'll
we'll save a few send us um soundboard
options I think that would be funny
inshallah we can add them with that
being said um I'm literally my
electronics are dying right um
so let's go ahead and unlock the stream
any final words from uh from you guys
per usual for having me on it's always
an honor shout out tortoise King it was
awesome being able to speak with him and
um
how to guide all these people that we
are discussing and make it easy for them
to find a slam
I mean Jabra do you do recitations
um inshallah I mean I do but inshallah
must start I want to start posting on
YouTube soon so you guys can you know
put me in your intro
we'll put you on bro yeah
for joining and everyone who joined us
today with that being said
we got us we gotta shout out the guest
on Saturday bro hype it up
oh yeah decided we got Abu American
coming on to uh dismantle the likes of
the red pill Community Insha'Allah
explain why Islam is triumphant again
with that being said I'll see you guys
next week
boy but again